Australia a country known for its
beaches a million different animals that
could kill you and now apparently
shit-ton of esports match-fixing
in 2019 alone six low level csgo matches
were allegedly fixed up to thirty
thousand dollars has allegedly been won
often illicit bets five search warrants
have been executed and six people have
been arrested so far and I haven't even
gotten to overwatch yet what in the hell
is going on in the world of Australian
eSports okay so back on February 27th a
low-level game of Australian csgo was
played and there was talk of match
fixing
but then in March the Australia police
launched an investigation into match
fixing in illegal betting in the
Australian csgo scene after being tipped
off by betting company Sportsbet two
semi-pro csgo players were arrested in
connection but the other four players on
the team were cleared of any wrongdoing
now I reached out to the Victoria Police
Department and they gave me a press
release that states at least five
matches were allegedly fixed and over 20
bets were allegedly placed and it's
reportedly the first investigation of
its kind for the department so here's
the deal this story is obviously still
developing so I'll try to update you as
new information comes in it's also worth
mentioning that all the names of the
people involved with this investigation
haven't been made public yet anyway the
two initial players were charged with
anything and they were eventually
released but shortly after that five
search warrants were issued and six
people were arrested in connection with
this alleged match-fixing now according
to the press release all six have been
interviewed in relation to the offences
of engaging in conduct that corrupts or
would corrupt a betting outcome of an
event or event contingency or use of
corrupt conduct information for betting
purposes in other words the cops are
talking to him you have no idea why
you're gonna run no idea so why you got
hair coming out your nose I did a bit
more digging and ended up speaking to
Neil Patterson who's the assistant
commissioner of the Victoria Police
Department now when Patterson spoke to
ABC News Australia about this
investigation he says he could quote
absolutely guarantee that this wouldn't
be the only alleged incident of match
fixing or betting anomalies on eSports
environments in the
Australian market holy [ __ ]
additionally Paterson stated that at the
heart of all of this were allegations
that to csgo players told their
associates to bet on these alleged fixed
matches now Paterson believes that
around $30,000 could have been made off
these bets dozens of more people could
be involved and we could see a lot more
of these corruption cases pop up in the
near future
now of course match-fixing is nothing
new in the world of Counter Strike or
eSports just look at the iBUYPOWER
scandal from 2014 or hell we even made
our own video about match fixing in
eSports so on one hand we really
shouldn't be surprised that this is
happening but on the other hand holy
[ __ ] I can't believe this is happening
that's a Bri jeez it certainly felt like
this era was behind us but I guess that
there's no end date for kids making
stupid mistakes those bones Shh
you know okay so you're still with me
right let's get into overwatch so the
overwatch contenders League it's
basically a farm league system that
feeds up-and-coming talent into the
overwatch league proper and according to
the Victoria Police Department there are
allegations of organized crime being
connected to a team at the ownership
level on top of that season two of the
2019 season was the first time the
contenders league was broadcasted live
previously the games were played on the
weekend and then streamed on a Monday or
a Tuesday so if you're a part of that
inner circle that was around when the
game was played you can place a bet on
the outcome before the game is
unrestrained now I'm just a small-time
Pizza learn but if you're gonna place a
bet on a game and you already know the
outcome [ __ ] son that's illegal and it's
currently part of what I'm looking into
and on top of all that I'm looking into
players not being paid management taking
legal action to stop players from
playing for other teams and management
trying to take all of Blizzard earnings
from those players all of this is
happening in the midst of the Victorian
Government hosting the Melbourne eSports
open a five-year initiative that will
reportedly generate twenty five million
dollars for the state so just to catch
you up over in Australia we have at
least five cases of match-fixing a whole
whack of arrests $30,000 in illicit bets
cases of players allegedly not getting
paid in the overwatch contenders League
and maybe organized crime now at the
time of publishing this video neither
valve nor Activision Blizzard have made
a statement on this matter but we're
actively pursuing comment I also have a
bunch of names dates and teams and I'm
currently looking into and when I have
something more concrete to share you'll
be the first to know what was it boy do
you wanted to do oh good night mate
let's go bit by a spider it's a [ __ ]
snake shop the dingo take
let me report it well okay
[Music]